damn she was fly
shy yo man can i ask you a question yeah
what why everybody messing with the
batman's
see that's exactly what i've been asking
myself it don't make no sense why would
you
do it why would you do that why would
you try and mess with the batman it's
seal tile it is
don't remember keith ledger's tribe i
mean the batman's got armor and be
knowing some
don't mushrooms i got armor and then
martial arts come on all you got is a
purple suit and some pancakes
come on man i mean come on man why would
you mess with the batman that's what i'm
saying man
remember when danny devito's tried it
walking
[Music]
is a multi-billionaire with a grudge
you're just a little fat [ __ ] in
a tuxedo
with an umbrella exactly man it's like a
pretend bird
can't mess with the batman no way no way
out of the question man
jim carrey's though jim carrey's
jim kim riddle me this riddle me
that man's how's this mature are going
to mess with batman
how's ayton talk well played hey batman
so i've come to get you
yeah i see how are you supposed to block
a batarang from going in your butt with
a carefully crafted query you cannot
that's how
it's impossible apes apes michelle put
fighters michelle perfect michelle
pfeiffer tried to message the batman
michelle
tried to mess with the batman
try to mess with the batman michelle
pfeiffer's shopify guess what michelle
pfeiffer's you ain't a real cat
come on i'll tell you one thing ain't no
way you gonna meows
with the batman moving about arnold
schwarzenegger though
what's arnold schwarzenegger trying to
do what is on the screen
feel the burn feel the burn feel the
burn it should be in your triceps oh
come on you can't turn up the ac and
think that's going to mess with the
battery what are you supposed to be
doing to the batman giving the batman's
a call
giving the batman's a sniffle talk about
bat losses
and you're defeated come on come in you
know there is one person though
oh no no no he'll come now there is one
person who could you come
right now mm-hmm
[Music]
he gave the batman's his skills he's a
mirror image of the batman
and fighting power
played by the incomparable liam neeson
so even when we are talking about the
batman's
liam neeson's is my shame
you